اعياد راس السنه في موسكو هذا العام تختلف
عن صديقاتها يودع الروس سنه حافله بدات
باعلان العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا لتجر
خلفها عواقب اقتصاديه واجتماعيه وعقوبات
على البلاد تشكلات صعب ان ثقيلا على
كاهلهم ويستقبلون عاما جديدا اخر مجهول
المصير
الاعتياديه للتهنئه بالعام الجديد والتي
اعتاد الحديث فيها عن الصعوبات وتحديات
الهائله لكل عام وعن مستقبل روسيا واميها
وتمنيات بعيدا سعيد والتي اصبح لها اخر
على الاذان الان
اتوقع ان كلمه الرئيس لم تختلف عن الاعوام
السابقه
بان يتم حل كل القضايا وسيكون كل شيء جيدا
وسيحل السلام
في الساحه الحمراء التي تنبا ببدايه العام
الجديد تتصاعد الدعوات لعقد محادثات
السلام بين موسكيز وليبدا فصل جديد في
العمليات العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
التي توعد وزير الدفاع روسي باستمرارها
حتى تحقيق جميع اهدافها كانت طعمه العربيه
موسكو
[موسيقى]